.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Charles: THANKS VERY MUCH.
I WANT TO GET TO IT WITH OUR
NEXT GUEST.
TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY, LIEUTENANT CHRIS
OLIVERAS.
THESE NUMBERS ARE STAGGERS.
WHAT SHOULD WE KNOW?
WHEN WE HEAR NUMBERS LIKE THIS,
600,000 GOT-AWAYS, ALMOST HALF
OF THE ENCOUNTERS HAD TO BE
RELEASED INTO THIS COUNTRY.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO BEGIN,
CHRIS.
>> WELL, YOU'RE RIGHT ON POINT,
CHARLES.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU, IT SHOULD
BE CONCERNING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU SEE -- WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE FAMILIES OR
THE CHILDREN BUT THE SINGLE
ADULTS THAT ARE COMING ACROSS
OUR BORDER INTO THE INTERIOR.
SOME OF THOSE WITH CRIMINAL
HISTORY, CRIMINAL GANG MEMBERS,
POTENTIAL TERRORISTS.
WE'VE SEEN THAT.
THE U.S. BORDER PATROL HAS SEEN
THAT AS WELL.
THIS IS OUR REALITY OF THE
CURRENT BORDER CRISIS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO ESCALATE.
WE'VE SEEN THAT BY OUR NUMBERS.
62,000 RELEASED IN THE COUNTRY
FROM JANUARY.
THAT IS A STAGGERING NUMBER
COMPARED TO THE PREVIOUS YEARS.
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE AS FAR AS
RELEASING INDIVIDUALS IN THE
INTERIOR.
BORDER AGENTS AND DPS PERSONNEL
ARE TRYING TO PROVIDE THE
MANPOWER, TECHNOLOGY IN ORDER TO
APPREHEND THE INDIVIDUALS AND TO
STEM THE FLOW OF MIGRATION.
BECAUSE OF THE MESSAGING AND THE
FACT THAT A MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
BEING RELEASED IN THE INTERIOR
DOESN'T HELP THE SITUATION.
>> Charles: WHERE ARE THEY GOING
ONCE THEY'RE RELEASED TO THE
INTERIOR?
>> A GREAT QUESTION.
A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
WE HAVE KNOWN THAT SOME OF THOSE
FLIGHTS, SOME OF THE
CORRESPONDENTS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
BREAK SOME STORIES.
WE'VE SEEN SOME FLIGHTS FLOWN
THROUGH LATE NIGHT HOURS THROUGH
OTHER STATES.
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE MENTIONED THE GOT-AWAYS.
THOSE ARE ONLY GOT-AWAYS THAT
ARE REPORTED.
THERE'S THOSE THAT DON'T SET OFF
ANY CENSORS OR CAMERAS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY'RE AT.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS IN THE
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS THE REALITY OF THE
SITUATION.
SHOULD BE CONCERNING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BECAUSE IT IS A
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT.
NOT ONLY TO THE STATE OF TEXAS
BUT TO THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
>> Charles: WHEN YOU INTERVIEW
THE MIGRANTS, WHAT DO YOU THEY
TELL YOU?
HAVE THEY BEEN I'M BOLD YELLED
BY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
WHAT WAS SAID ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL AND THE FACT THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS LOOKING THE OTHER
WAY AS THIS HAPPENS?
DO THEY FEEL EMBOLDENED LIKE
THEY'VE BEEN INVITED?
>> THEY DO BECAUSE OF THE
MESSAGING THAT WE SAW IN
DECEMBER OF 2020.
THAT IS THE PURPOSE WHY WEE SEE
THIS FLOW OF MASS MYGATION.
NOT ONLY THAT, BUT THE DRUG
TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATIONS
EXPLOITING THAT MESSAGING.
THEY'RE PROFITING BILLIONS OFF
OF HUMAN SMUGGLING.
BECAUSE OF THAT, WE'RE SEEING
THIS INFLUX OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION TAKING PLACE AND
IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE.
THAT IS THE REASON WHY GOVERNOR
ABBOTT LAUNCHED OPERATION LONE
STAR TO CRACK DOWN AND TO
SUPPORT OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE OVERWHELMED
AND THEIR HANDS ARE TIED.
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO DO THE JOB
THEY WANT TO.
THAT IS UP ON THE BORDER AND
TRYING TO APPREHEND THE
INDIVIDUALS COMING ACROSS.
>> Charles: IT'S ADMIRABLE ON
THE PART OF THE STATE BUT THIS
FEELS LIKE A NATIONAL CRISIS.
IS THERE ANY HOPE OF GETTING ANY
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL HELP?
>> RIGHT NOW, CHARLES, WE'RE NOT
SEEING THAT.
WE DON'T EXPECT THAT ON THE
STATESIDE.
EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE DEPLOYING
WITH OPERATION LONE STAR AS FAR
AS TECHNOLOGY AND STATE FUNDING,
IT'S ALL FROM THE STATE OF
TEXAS, FROM OUR STATE LEADERS.
WE'RE NOT GETTING ANY TYPE OF
SUPPORT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
CONSTRUCTING THE FIRST EVER
BORDER TEXAS WALL, THAT'S STATE
FUNDS.
THAT WON'T STOP US DOING WHAT
WE'RE DOING.
WE'RE CONTINUING TO MOVE FORWARD
BECAUSE WE HAVE DEDICATED MEN
AND WOMEN DEDICATED TO THIS JOB
AND SAFEGUARDING TEXANS.
>> Charles: MAKE SUR